[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we
want we got cat back here today
how has life been for ya lately uh it's
been good it's been a little weird oh
we're under attack this is the last
episode of off the right under the
tables
i'll save you guys
[Laughter]
uh it was good i recently did david's
podcast
and i like blacked out halfway through
were you drinking
no i just got excited and i forgot what
i said
and then like i went home afterwards
realized half the things i said and had
to prep my boyfriend like hey i know
you're really proud of it but i said a
lot
everyone opens up like crazy on this
podcast and everyone ends up crying too
he told me people usually end up crying
i did not end up crying i ended up
talking about anal which is
kind of better honestly you cry during
that yeah
yeah you cry from your eye yeah it's
like everyone cries on david so you're
like i'm gonna flip it
i'm gonna flip it i'm gonna go in there
and talk about anal here
yeah you got so excited uh being with
david that like
being on geniusbrain or what um i think
i'm because of what i do for work i'm
usually like
i'm not the main person talking in the
podcast that i work for
i'm kind of like i chime in and i do
current events
this and genius brain and big mood were
the like first times like i got to talk
as
me rather than like oh i'm doing a job i
have like these little segments that i
do
and i got i don't know if it's
excitement or just like
a switch went off and i was like like i
don't remember anything
i don't remember anything and then i
re-listened to the podcast like
oh i said that oh okay and now i
understand why some people say like they
don't remember what they say in podcast
oh interesting oh i get it did you did
you listen to these podcasts with your
boyfriend you know i just i went home
and i told them like hey i
vaguely remember talking about anal i
remember
talking about this this and this um do
that information what you will
i i am so sorry
[Laughter]
he was like oh okay i mean like i'm
literally [ __ ] on the internet so
like that's fine yeah oh cool yeah
that's good he's reasonable he's very
reasonable this guy
yeah reasonable he gets it i like how
he's not a judger
yeah there's no double standard you know
that's the nice thing about it
yeah i don't remember anything about
what just anything in general
oh that's pretty is that why you refer
to geo for all your stories and you know
the funny thing
i don't remember anything honestly i
really don't absolutely
i don't remember what i say on shows
like um we'll go on vacation
and then like i don't remember half the
things that went on in the vacation
until people started talking about it
and i'm like oh yeah that did happen you
could revisit your vlogs like it's the
first time
like you're watching a different person
yeah that's what's cool about vlogging
but just like
we never watch our vlogs either yeah but
just i don't know i don't know kind of
weird if you do though yeah
you're like taking the time like oh that
was a good bit yeah now
i we don't do that yeah i just think my
hard drive's full or something
what but what do you what do you think
about i mean look i
i think i think about things but not but
you don't retain any
of that information yeah it's not in my
hard drive i'm just thinking about
what's happening now
or in the future but a lot of like my
memory
like i don't remember like there's
things that happened maybe even a year
ago that much
you're not present maybe i'm too present
yeah
what maybe i'm not present no i think i
think not present or something
really yeah well they say that like like
at the end of the day when you do a
bunch of stuff yeah
you should always kind of think about
what you did because
like your memory is a muscle that you
have to kind of train too yeah so like
if you're not exercising that then it's
gonna be really easy for you to be like
i don't know what the [ __ ] i did
dude bart's gonna start [ __ ] setting
up reps and sets and [ __ ] we're gonna
bring program he's an hour
yeah a white board was like hey remember
everything i did today but that they
there was like some uh this really smart
guy's name's like james quicker i'm glad
you remember james
oh james i i know what you're talking
about yeah he's like a brain
yeah yeah the memory guy yeah he was
talking about that [ __ ] he was like at
the end of the day
if you feel like you have a hard time we
can't remember [ __ ] maybe i need to do
it too
you said what i heard he doesn't sleep
he don't sleep because he's so smart bro
he's always thinking he can't sleep
he hasn't sleep and slept in a couple
years or something because he's
memorizing things no our buddy benny
knows him and then they had dinner and
[ __ ] he was talking on his podcast about
how he sleeps so much
and how sleeping maybe he had to because
he hasn't slept in three years his eyes
were all bloodshot
he just like tired he's fall asleep
everywhere he says he couldn't sleep he
had this crazy case of
insomnia so he started to just meditate
for long periods of time
while snoring nice and drooling
yeah do you guys do like meditation or
anything ever that's hot on the streets
i try and then i start thinking and i
said [ __ ] i ain't doing this right
i'm like man i'm bored and i go swimming
or something yeah no i tried that's how
my meditation goes to i try i'm like 10
minutes today right now let's go
and then it's like one minute later i'm
like oh [ __ ] i'm like i'm already
stressing out about some other [ __ ]
while i'm meditating like i don't think
i'm doing this right
let's go just focus on breathing and
looking at [ __ ]
yeah it's pretty good oh you don't close
your eyes when you meditate you could do
all kinds of different styles
there's different styles of it yeah
what's your favorite style my style is
like
looking at the sugar cane leaves and
it's going like this
and then i go don't say nothing don't
say nothing don't say nothing and then
you just repeat
whatever over and over and over and you
go wait how long am i supposed to do
this oh [ __ ] i started thinking
about it maybe don't take his tips yeah
don't take his tips yeah you know what i
say take those tips bro that sounds good
that sounds a good place to start yep
the tip yeah cause you're not supposed
to be
when you make it too intense then it's
not meditating you gotta start somewhere
right you're thinking too hard about it
you're when you start meditation you're
not gonna be [ __ ] really good at it
you're gonna be okay when i meditate i
open my coinbase account yeah and i go
please go up
you start rubbing your neck
[Laughter]
bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin it doesn't go
anywhere i don't know how many things
work
i feel like it's you gotta have a
screensaver
yeah perfect that feels great
what is uh meditating supposed to do
like keep you grounded and like centered
be more present i think yeah i think
that reason
like they call it mindfulness yeah so
you're supposed to like be
very mindful of everything like the way
you breathe um
like the noises outside your house or
whatever and just kind of like
everything's okay you kind of it's like
self-reflection and kind of like
asserting like you know you don't need
to be so tense
and like stressed out and i think it'll
help you remember
what ocean you poop in because the fact
how many times now that i'm thinking
about it
the fact that you had to ask gio like
hey remember that time i [ __ ] in the
ocean
and she's a life event dude yeah like
that's something yeah
memorable yeah that's like a scar in
your brain you should be thinking about
some ways
there's a lot of [ __ ] that happens all
the time yeah
that it's talking about like [ __ ] yeah
it becomes kind of average and normal
so we have to this is part two of our
earlier conversation
do you just [ __ ] in random places a lot
no but a lot of like
i feel like my life's exciting
it is exciting yeah it's like a lot of
stuff happens you know like it's so
exciting it becomes normal and then you
don't mind to remember
it like when you when you like when
you're with david right like yeah
the amount of like um like tragedies
and like just like the crazy [ __ ] that
happens it happens
all the time where it's unbelievable
right yeah mind if it is the glass of
man
yeah mine's not like that but it's like
on the other side where there are a lot
of exciting things that happen
not just like exciting like winning the
lottery but like [ __ ] in the ocean
like that kind of [ __ ] that i don't
but i would still argue that [ __ ] in
the ocean is still
a very unique situation across the board
it's like a statement i don't think you
know his life
yeah okay yeah like is then for you
because i think you're looking at it
from like the lens of your life and
going if that happened to me for sure
it'd stand out but
he just the [ __ ] that happens to him and
like just the [ __ ] that
like i should use a better word but like
the events that occur
in his day-to-day come out of this guy
when i'm snorkeling
when i'm snorkeling i'm actually in fish
mode okay
no i don't think i remember i'm
remembering it so i'm not in like
comedian mode
i'm not in human you're not you're right
the dad mode yeah i'm not like husband
this is a great story that i'll save for
later i'm like literally
i got a [ __ ] you're not and i'm going
into the other
yeah and i'm just i'm in fish mode and
then
and then i just go live my fish life
yeah and then i come out when you pooped
was your poop really long and like seven
feet long
and it dangles from your ass another
human being
this [ __ ] it looks like they're throwing
away their intestines
humans come by you're like i'm gonna get
eaten [ __ ] so i'd like to put that into
perspective as well
uh he has another hat it's a science hat
and he wants to
touch because you know how everyone
always says steve has a big dick yeah so
he wants to feel
steve's big hard dick see that's another
hat so then he'll probably forget that
he even touched his dick
if i'm a fish mother that makes more
sense to me though that makes more sense
to me
because it's for you want to understand
the weight the inertia that steve's dick
carries you know like yeah the mass of
it you wanna i don't have that many
memories either
yeah yeah i don't look back i look
forward a lot
yeah there might be a lot of crazy [ __ ]
that's going on and then
so like whatever seems crazy isn't that
crazy because there's so many of them
today's video
is brought to you by feels cbd
isn't about what you feel but it's about
what you do not feel
like stress maybe a little bit of
anxiety
maybe a little bit of these feelings in
your heart that's like
i need to calm down and [ __ ] for me i
wanted to feel a little bit more relaxed
recently
i was in utah with some friends and you
know a lot of people like to drink to
relax and bond
but me i'm allergic to alcohol and i
feel kind of left out i'm like oh man i
don't want to drink some
immediately get a headache but i also
want to do any other crazy ass [ __ ]
because i do like
being sober and just enjoying myself so
i'm like oh cool i brought some field
cbd with me
take a couple drops i felt relaxed i
felt i was still able to bond and be
with everyone
i don't have the exact i don't have the
anxious feeling of like you might be the
only sober one here what the hell's
happening
and i was able to just bond and kick it
with everyone else in my own way
i don't have to have a red face and have
a headache 30 minutes later so that was
super cool
if you're interested in cbd it really
helps with pain anxiety stress
all that stuff they even have a hotline
to walk you through it so you have all
the support that you need
just go to fields.com off the record
that's f
e a l s to get 50 off your first order
plus free shipping when you become a
member that's fuels.com
off the record to get 50 off plus free
shipping
get some feels and a massage and it
feels real good
feels good i have more future memories
in my mind than the past
future memories like you guys are
explaining like your brain's mechanism
to shut memories off because of trauma
yep
i feel like that's what it is it's
trauma oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] went deep
i don't necessarily think it's like you
don't remember i think your brains were
good at
not remembering a lot of things in life
and rewriting what happened in life
yeah yeah that's why we're comedians wow
that's actually kind of tight though
yeah
like i noticed when i'm driving if i put
the gps on
and i'm just following the gps i won't
remember how i got somewhere
because i think i'm present with the gps
but
you saw the line yeah so i'm just
memorizing the line right area
that's never happened to you when you
get home you're like oh yeah but if i go
you know what [ __ ] the gps this time i'm
just gonna go okay left on here right on
here left on here i'm gonna remember
that and i don't
and i think now i'm actually more
present with the real world rather than
being present with the gps then i
actually remember
where i went the scenery the landscapes
true
yeah i think i'm more present now
because i don't
fight when no one's around what
what do you mean like by myself in the
on the street
like or like in the shower or like
whatever
wait like what do you mean fight like
like you get into a
head argument and it comes out into the
real life
oh i guess that's how we all took it but
i think we want i think we want more
like you're fighting with yourself
yeah or like i'm [ __ ] injecting hands
with invisible people like i was taking
like i told you guys
i took a shower right and i started
thinking about being in malaysia
like back in the day when we went to
malaysia we're eating great food
and i was like but what if they
kidnapped me yeah
you know and i'm like [ __ ] oh but
what if like they put me in the shower
and i'm like [ __ ] scrubbing up for
this guy that wants to [ __ ] do dirty
things to me and [ __ ] yeah and i'm like
oh yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] you papa i'm a [ __ ] fighting his
ass naked and then before i know it like
i'm in the living room [ __ ] kicking
ass and [ __ ] and i'm like
[ __ ] and i got soaps good and everything
has got water everywhere
i relate to that but instead of fighting
with myself in my head i pick a fight
with my boyfriend and then i'm mad at
him
you didn't even do nothing wrong yeah
you're like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] what's your comment well most
common made up scenario of you getting
manageable because this sounds it
happens everywhere uh
i feel like [ __ ] off i'd say two weeks
ago i was
upstairs trying to take a nap and he was
downstairs watching tv
and right as i was going to like go out
and finally nap
just like something in my mind came in
and was like
he used to [ __ ] other [ __ ] suddenly
like i went from like
like drowsy he's like undertaking like
oh [ __ ]
i walked i like marched downstairs like
[ __ ] hobbling
and then i see him like little ass and
he's just like smiling at me like
hi babe did you go to sleep i'm like
you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's like what is happening yeah like
are you okay i'm like
i came down here to let you know that i
know you [ __ ] other [ __ ] you tell
him girl
he's like like my ex girlfriend like
people i've dated before i knew you were
like yeah
and that's [ __ ] yeah serious took a
nap good for you maybe it's in our asian
dna dude like i don't know
like to start fights with invisible
creatures
it sounds like it yeah because the other
day i was uh
we have a wall full of leaves right like
vines and [ __ ]
and i was up to the [ __ ] vines like
and i saw [ __ ] leia and the two
little babies on my window going hi
uncle joe and i was like oh hi
i'm like hella embarrassed because i'm
like oh
why do they have to see that outside of
me like i feel so bad like i don't ever
want to
show children my aggression your aunt's
gonna come up to you you're safe i think
they probably thought it was funny
and be like yo what's wrong with the
kids like they just start talking to the
planes start fighting
yeah you hey joe do you have any idea
why they're doing that you're like [ __ ]
i don't know man your kids are crazy
i don't know what's happening we got
dangling ass [ __ ]
lemon trees and [ __ ] and i see the lemon
and i thought blah [ __ ] yeah you might
be [ __ ] bigger but i got you
[ __ ]
and then like i'm like i hope christina
didn't see that i start yelling about
you know i start
fighting like i'm yelling you know yeah
but i like that though that's kind of
tight because you got to practice those
situations yeah but i feel like a
homeless man on crack just
fighting invisible people yeah that
happens all the time and i'm like oh
those guys are just misunderstood
they're just getting ready for
situations too
oh maybe they're not you will be more
ready than the person that doesn't
practice that's true
what you practice gets better kind of
really sometimes yeah
the person that comes up to them is a
[ __ ] flat surface with
like leaves all over dangling and they
don't move yeah yeah you will [ __ ] them
up
you're ready that situation is or a
lemon that's right
flowers out there you better watch out
foo i'll kick the pedals off your face
i do practice that at home because we
have a place where we keep like the
emergency
pistol what's that when i press the code
yeah this [ __ ] will hear a noise
outside
and i'm like oh can you go check it out
and instead of grabbing it flashlight
because i gotta go get the gun the
flashlight's on the gun man
i'm like are you [ __ ] i'll go outside
it's okay no i gotta wait a second let
me put on my combat boots
yeah this one's getting ripped you
should have a duster right next to the
uh
like a big giant black coat that you
have right next to the pistol so when
you're about to get ready to go to
battle you
throw that on no he has his paint that
he grabs he goes like this and he goes
all right
but before that little cat before that
was dirt i'd take a shower first
would you hear that [ __ ] yeah i go in
the shower first i could take a shower
prepare for battle yeah
[Laughter]
now get your cameras out
[Laughter]
or you have a home alone situation you
have booby traps all over the house oh
yeah that's smart
yeah i have a bunch of marbles
everywhere so this case where the
burger's coming i do miss having a dog
because of that yeah you know they could
sense
or even hear things yeah so you could
just be chilling and then they're like
and then you're like oh what the hell's
happening that's why we couldn't get you
for your birthday
oh yeah dogs gave it away yeah i feel
like bart cannot set up traps because
he'll forget where the traps were and
then get caught in it
yeah you mean the memory stuff no i
don't think that's a problem yeah
i don't think that's a problem he
doesn't even know what you're talking
about
he has no point of reference at [ __ ]
all he's i'll help him set it up and
also forget
[Laughter]
don't put this here [ __ ] [ __ ] god damn
it they're fighting each other
we have no punching each other because
we think
we're burglarizing our house it's a joke
but like it could happen though
for these guys like a friendly fire dude
do you ever get mad at bart for like the
same story as that cat just told
i mean maybe you should ask bart because
i might not remember but i would like to
say no just black out
i would like to say no but you let me
know babe
um i just i've seen chicks just get
pissed off for no reason
yeah so there's not not just you but
just like like hanging out do i do it
yeah you do you do you do
the group like a group setting sometimes
i just see chicks start flipping out and
i was like what the [ __ ]
yeah the [ __ ] happening we'll be
watching a tv show and my wife is like
the character might be like cheating on
like having an affair or something
and she goes if you ever do that exactly
and i'm like but it's not for real
pissed
no i'm not you guys don't hurt us though
you guys don't know that though but it's
also like i was like i've never done
anything to
even why am i getting in trouble i was
like what's the point of me being
faithful if you're
just gonna accuse me anyway i like that
you have like [ __ ] like
fighter ears and she's like i will [ __ ]
you up yeah
like no i think you can just [ __ ] with
you like [ __ ] and she like threatens me
she lists all the threats
and i'm like oh like this is just a tv
show it's him
that's not me she marked her territory
you're not gonna think about anymore
because if you do you're going to be
like the thing
chicks flip out for no [ __ ] no reason
bro i give her no reason
guys don't watch a movie with the chick
and then like the girls key in the guy's
car
if you will
[Laughter]
yes we know it's a movie we're just
chilling
make believe bro yeah this is this has
nothing to do with any of us
i did that watching true detective with
my boyfriend every time a white guy
cheats i look at him like [ __ ]
people do woody harrelson looking
god damn it i'm like here we go again
okay blue eyes
yeah very good show by the way very good
shots
she's the one very if you ever steal my
dragon eggs
we're going to [ __ ] you up
[Music]